hey what's up everybody its Warren and
this morning we finally got the official
trailer for spider-man fire from home
and it was awesome I absolutely loved it
I did a breakdown video of it earlier
today but it seems like some people
don't know that Sony and Marvel actually
released an international trailer as
well that has different footage it's got
about 30 seconds of different scenes
than the u.s. trailer so in this video
I'll be breaking that down and the whole
trailer as well as I mentioned in my
video earlier on today this is
technically the first trailer for phase
4 of the MCU so it's really exciting and
the trailer was just phenomenal
there's a lot to talk about a lot to
break down and some Easter eggs as well
and some tiny tiny hints at Avengers
endgame now it's not mentioned at all in
the trailer nor are the events of
Avengers infinity war but that was
expected they're not going to give
anything away about Avengers in game in
this trailer so let's just jump right
into it so I'm going to be breaking down
both trailers in this video I'm going to
combine them and talk about them
chronologically I will let you know when
I'm discussing scenes that are in the
International trailer so the first scene
we have is spider-man
and Aunt May at an event supporting the
homeless so if you remember the last
scene for spider-man homecoming Aunt May
now knows that Peter is spider-man and
it looks like she accepted it pretty
well and actually looks pretty excited
about it enough for her to go to events
with him and high-five him after at
least so then we have happy hogan coming
after and this is where we see the
romance between him and Aunt May there
was talking about a romance between
happy and Aunt May after the trailer was
shown at Cece xB in South Paulo Brazil
and now we're finally seeing it on
screen and it's very noticeable they're
doing it on purpose obviously showing
that there's a romance between them and
Peter is kind of like what the heck is
going on because he can tell - so in the
next scene you see Peter Parker packing
and he says that he's going to Europe on
a school trip so this is obviously
setting up the fact that he's going to
be far from home he's not gonna be in
New York he's going to be in Europe but
in this next scene is something really
really interesting we see spider-man
swinging around in the city and in the
back is the old Avengers Tower so in
spider-man homecoming
we learned that Tony Stark actually sold
the old Avengers Tower and the Avengers
headquarters moved to upstate New York
well as you can see in this still
somebody has already bought the building
and has begun renovations on it since
the trailer showed at CC XP there has
been talk and rumors that this could be
a fantastic four building or a Norman
Osborn building out of the - it's more
than likely a Norman Osborn building we
haven't seen him in the MCU and he's a
huge part of spider-man
and at the time that this was filming
and still currently Disney and Marvel do
not own the rights to use the Fantastic
Four in the MCU so it's more than likely
an Osborn building so the next scene
shows Peter Parker going to pick up a
passport and this is actually a really
cool Easter Egg if you notice his date
of birth on the passport says August
10th that's actually the date that
Spiderman appeared for the very first
time in the comics August of 1962 so
that's a cool little easter egg they did
there so the next scene is a pretty big
scene he's trying to pack for his trip
and Aunt May tells him to pack his
spider-man suit but he doesn't want to
pack his spider-man suit we hear him say
I just want to go on a trip with my
friends so he doesn't want to go with
spider-man who wants to go ask Peter
Parker he kind of wants to put down that
mantle just for a little bit so he can
enjoy this vacation with his friends and
he even says that Europe doesn't need a
friendly neighborhood spider-man but
another big thing about this scene is
that if you look at his spider-man suit
this is not the iron spider suit so he
doesn't have the iron spider suit for
some reason Kevin Feige has already come
out and said that this movie is not a
prequel to infinity war or Avengers
endgame so that leaves us with the
question why doesn't he have his iron
spider suit why does he have his old
suit this is obviously something that we
probably won't figure out until after
avengers endgame has come out in
theaters and then there's a really cool
easter egg where we see Peter close his
suitcase you can tell that his suitcase
is pretty old it looks pretty beat up
but on it has the initials BFP the
initials stand for
Ben F Parker which of course is Uncle
Ben so this is his Uncle Ben's suitcase
that he now has so Peter Parker doesn't
actually pack his spider-man suit but in
the International trailer we learned
that Aunt May actually did in the
International trailer it starts off with
Peter Parker having already packed up
his things and is already at the airport
going through customs a woman who works
for customs is
going through his suitcase and when she
opens his suitcase what did we see right
there on top is his spider-man suit
with a little note for mom a saying you
almost forgot this so Peter actually
left his suit at home
but Aunt May knowing that he might need
it while he's in London packed it for
him
good call on May so Peter is freaking
out because this woman at customs is
seeing his spider-man suit and he's
afraid that she's going to know who he
is
but as it turns out she just tells him
that he can't bring a banana through
customs because you can't bring food
through customs and then in the
International trailer it shows Peters
friends going through customs starting
with MJ and then it shows Ned and Betty
and what's interesting here is that
Betty's got her hand on Ned's shoulder
and Ned seems to have a newfound
confidence in this trailer so maybe
there's a little bit of romance going on
between the two of them as well it then
shows Peter Parker and his friends
taking off and landing in Europe and
then also in the International trailer
we hear Peter and Ned talking Ned is
telling Peter that they have two weeks
in Europe and it's gonna be great and
then Peter says I'm just going to enjoy
my trip and hang out with them J and
this is where we see the romance start
between him and MJ and if you notice
they actually all call her MJ no it's a
pretty funny scene they showed the
awkwardness of Peter Parker trying to
flirt with MJ here and she's just
messing with him and then going back to
a scene that is in the international
trailer and not the US trailer we
actually see Peter and MJ taking a nice
little romantic walk together but
ultimately you can tell that they both
like each other and this is the start of
a romance and we can hear Peter talking
to Ned about that in the next scene in
their hotel room where he says I just
want to spend some time with MJ I think
she really likes me dude and then BAM
Ned gets hit in the net with a tranq
dart from Nick Fury knocking him out
so I've already seen some people
wondering why didn't it Peter spidey
senses go off and tell him that Nick
Fury was in his room cuz as you can see
this takes him by total surprise but yes
he does have spidey senses we saw this
in Avengers infinity war but they did
not go off because Nick Fury is not a
threat to him just like in spider-man
homecoming where his spidey senses then
it go off when Ned was in his room Ned
was not a threat to him and Nick Fury is
not a threat to him so his spidey senses
did not go off then Nick Fury introduces
himself in true Nick Fury fashion super
spy super
cool super casual Geist nice to finally
meet you
spider-man Peter instantly recognizes
that it's Nick Fury and although he has
never met him before he does know who he
is because of his involvement with
Ironman and happy also kind of funny to
see Nick Fury alive because the last
time we saw him he was turning to dust
again they're not going to give anything
about Avengers endgame away in this
trailer but Nick Fury clearly comes back
somehow so Nick Fury tells him to put
some clothes on let's go for a ride and
this is where he recruits spider-man for
a mission
we then see Peter with the spider-man
suit on in a boat with Nick Fury he
actually did bring his spider-man suit
they showed that to us in the
International trailer so he brought his
original suit but Nick Fury does still
give him new suits and we see that in
the very next scene where he's actually
wearing his red and black suit and it is
actually a glider which is super cool
it's really awesome to see them bring
that into this movie and as you can see
he's using the suit to fly towards this
chaos and destruction that is happening
on this bridge in London we learned that
this chaos and destruction is actually
the elementals attacking the elementals
are extra-dimensional humanoids who
basically have control over the elements
of the earth in the comics there are
four of them hydron who is the Lord of
the waters Magnum who is the master of
the earth
Hellfire who is the wielder of flame and
Zephyr who is the mistress of the winds
so we hear Nick Fury tell Peter that
he's got gifts but he's got a job to do
and that job is to take out the
elementals and we actually see all of
the elementals throughout the trailer in
the scene we actually see Nick Fury and
Maria Hill fighting Magnum then we go
back to the bridge scene where there's a
lot of chaos going on and we see
lightning and we see fire and the
lightning is most likely Zephyr and the
fire is Hellfire we have another cool
scene that shows spider-man using his
glider suit to fly into the fire most
likely going to fight Hellfire which we
see very briefly in this still right
here and then we have a very interesting
scene with happy hogan happiest talking
to Peter and he says you are all alone
your friends are in trouble what are you
going to do about it if you want to
avoid any Avengers and game possible
spoilers at all skip ahead like 25
seconds why is happy telling Peter you
are all alone and why does Nick Fury
talk to spider-man direct
and we have not seen Tony Stark at all
in this trailer that could say something
about the events of Avengers endgame now
obviously if he is in spider-man far
from home they're not gonna show him in
this trailer they're not going to give
anything away about Avengers endgame but
just think about that we then see
spider-man drop in with a new all-black
suit
what this is is his stealth suit this
isn't something that Peter already had
this as something that Nick Fury gave to
him we know this because we have already
seen leaked photos and a leaked video of
Peter Parker in the spider-man stealth
suit we know this because in the leaked
photos we saw on spider-man's upper part
of his chest a shield logo and what's
actually very interesting about this
shot and the trailer is they actually
blocked out the logo not really a big
surprise here Marvel has been known to
do this they've been known to change and
tweak a little bit of the trailers to
try to avoid any spoilers that they can
but the stealth suit is basically
exactly what it sounds like
it helps Peter Parker be stealthy and go
about his business undetected the suit
sort of adapts to the environment
surrounding it and it also helps him see
at night we then go to a scene where
there is an attack from the water
elemental they haven't actually named
the elementals yet they could be going
with the original names or this could
actually be a version of hydro-man this
elemental attacks and we see Peter
Parker trying to help his friends and
everybody else get to safety then we see
the elemental just deliver a huge punch
to Peter Parker knocking him down and
you can tell that he's just very taken
back by how strong this elemental is and
then we have what I think is just the
very best part of the whole entire
trailer Mysterio shows up he makes an
epic drop in Dan it cuts to Peter Parker
hanging off the edge of a building
soaking wet and then Mysterio says you
don't want any part of this and then
begins to attack the water elemental we
see the beams come out of his hands and
then we see him fly and go fight the
water elemental so Mysterio is actually
a person named Quentin Beck and Quentin
Beck does not have any superhuman powers
at all but he is very very skilled and
talented he is an expert designer of
special effect devices and stage
illusions a master hypnotist and
magician and a chemist and roboticist so
he can create devices such as his suit
that allow him to fly and create smoke
and
if you look at his suit it actually
looks like Chitauri tech this is the
same tech that vulture from spider-man
homecoming was collecting so it's
possible that he got this tech from
vulture we know that Michael Keaton is
going to be in this movie as vulture so
maybe Mysterio got this tech from
vulture or maybe Peter Parker will have
to work with vulture somehow to take
down Mysterio because although this
trailer does depict Mysterio as a good
guy he is actually the villain in the
comics Mysterio actually wants to be a
hero he wants to be an Avenger so his
plan is to defeat spider-man and show
everybody that he's a better hero and
what Mysterio does is create illusions
and that is probably what the elementals
are and spider-man far from home
we learned from Jake Gyllenhaal himself
at cc XP that Mysterio gets recruited by
Nick Fury he gets recruited by Nick Fury
because he is supposed to be an expert
on these elementals but the reason he's
an expert on them is because he actually
is creating them they are his illusions
and his plan is to make it look like
he's actually a hero and a friend of
spider-man and then defeat spider-man
and again he looks awesome we even get
to see him where his fish ball helmet I
think the character is done amazingly I
think Jake Gyllenhaal is a perfect actor
to play Mysterio and overall this is
just a phenomenal trailer the next
trailer will probably come out after
Avengers end game and it will probably
give us a little bit more info because
we will have known what happens in
Avengers endgame so the next trailer
probably won't come until after Avengers
end game and that will be a full trailer
although this trailer is long and really
really awesome it's still a teaser
trailer so the next one should be a full
trailer and then we have the last scene
which is funny and ironic because we
have flash just praising spider-man
saying how much he loves them and then
he makes fun of Peter Parker and of
course they're the same person so that's
it for my full breakdown of the very
first spider-man far from home teaser
trailer let me know how awesome you
thought it was and let me know your
favorite part of the trailer in the
comments down below and just a heads up
I'm giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet if you'd like to enter the
giveaway for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero and be sure to subscribe so
you can stay up to date
everything related to spider-man far
from home Avengers in game and all
things Marvel as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]